[Musique]
citadel sentinelle depuis huit siècles
l'alhambra le château rouge en arabe
veille sur la ville de grenade
[Musique]
qu'il vente qu'il neige ou qu'il pleuve
les palais de l'alhambra attire chaque
année près de 3 millions de visiteurs
pierrette et félix viennent de l'essonne
c'est leur troisième visite
j'ai senti ça comme eux
presque le palais des mille et une nuits
shéhérazade qui ça
la méditation
au coeur du palais du sultan la cour des
lions
un joyau de l'art islamique
124 colonnes de marbre blanc et au
centre une fontaine d'albâtre portée par
12 lyon
il y avait des fontaines partout et elle
servait pour l'irrigation les bains et
les ablutions avant la prière
en rigole en bassin
en fontaine l'écoulement de l'eau est
ici parfaitement maîtrisé
les murs de l'alhambra sont comme des
livres ouverts les bas reliefs sculptés
sont des histoires des poèmes à la
gloire de la dynastie du maître des
lieux c'est magnifique c'est le plus bel
endroit que j'ai visités au monde
aux fusions
le céramique de plafond t
classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco l'alhambra par son raffinement
fait totalement oublier qu'elle a
d'abord été construite à des fins
militaires